はい それでやりたいことは成功するためにどうすればということですね
成功っていうのは 2つあります
無意味になる成功と有意義な成功
成功は成功ですけど 結局は何のためかと
虚しくなってしまう場合もあるし
成功して本当に良かったというものもあります
それから成功の基本 考えたから
計画を立てたから 努力したから
運が良かったからなどでは成功はしません
よく覚えてほしいんです
よく考えたから成功しましたと
ありえないんです  計画しっかり計画を立てたんだから成功しましたよと
そんなのはありえないんです
成功は因果律です これ
人も簡単に忘れるんですね
あの人は地道に計画を立てるんだから
何でも成功するそうと
ありえないんですよ あの人は運が良くてついているんだから
何やってもうまくいくと
それもあり得ないことなんです
成功っていうのは因果法則によって成り立つのものです
それには自分も他人もいません
ただの因果法則 原因条件によって原因とですけどね
決まっている結果が自ずと現れるんです
原因条件はちゃんと揃っておけば
自然に結果が出てきますよ
それが成功なんですよ
結果が出ましたと 成功を期待する人は
自我欲などを抑えて因縁のみを調べて揃うんですよ
だから成功したいと思う人が
私が私がというね やらなくちゃとかね
そういう自分がいるという気持ちを捨てる
捨てるんです これはまあ一般社会ではありえないんですけど
まあ本当に本格的な仏教徒なら
まあ自分を忘れて行動するんです
自分を忘れて まあ原因条件をそろそろだけ揃ってあげて
揃ってあげていくんです
そうすると自ずと結果が出ているんです
これは難しいでしょうと思いますけどね
例えば便所掃除しなさいというと
私がやるの？なんで私が
と思った瞬間で自我なんです
それでうまくいくわけじゃないんです
人生もそれでダメになっちゃうんです
ちょっとしたことじゃないんです
自分の人生っていうのは行為の連続だからね
間の一つの行為を失敗すると
この連続性が切れてますよ
ずいぶん好き勝手に生きてますけど
瞬間瞬間何かを行為をして生きているんです
だから行為をしっかり次から次へとつなげていないと
間でどうにもならん もうものすごい悪い行為になっちゃうと
人生全体的にもガタガタになります
将来的には崩れてしまいます
過去は終わったんだから大丈夫ですけど
だから仏教の世界では
いかなる行為でもすごい真剣にやるんです
いくらかこの日本の仏教でも
禅寺ではそういうところは結構教えてはいますけど
すごいつまらない仕事でも
ものすごい真剣にやらせるんです
これはもう無知な人々にとってはとてもいいことかもしれませんだけど
で あの それでこの何か宗教的
儀式的 業的な世界になってしまって
みんなそれに惹かれていくんです
そちらに座布団を置くことでも
しっかりと真剣に置くことは
何の儀式も何の行でもありません
今 日本の曹洞宗の貫主のお坊様がね
そういうところを一回だけ聞いたこと
テレビで聞いたことありますけどね
で その前で座布団があって
座布団の真ん中にあるあのなんとかあの
ちょっとあれなんて言いますかね
あのギザギザのなんか糸のね
束みたいなものありますね
それも揃って丁寧に一箇所に揃って置いて
座布団を置くんですね
それから４つのコーナーにあるあれもちゃんと揃って置いておくんです
で それ一般人が精神的に混乱している人から見れば
もう大変なことで見えますけど
そのお坊さんいうのは
そんなのはごく当たり前のこと
当たり前のこと 座布団を置いたならば
ボーンと捨てるんじゃないんです
座布団を置くという行為ですから
それが完全にする それだけの話
それならちゃえば 人生は全部何の問題もないでしょう
こんなことなんでバカなこと
それどうでもいいんじゃないかという気分になると
人生も本人の人生はね
どうでもいい加減な人生になるんです
なんでそう考えるのかと
自我なんですね 自分の考え方
俺はそれはバカバカしいと思いますよという
自分が思うことはどうでもいいゴミなんです
結局は自分という主体で思うものは
だから便所掃除しなさいと言ったら
そちらなるのは便所掃除という単なる行為だけ
人はいません だからその行為を行う自我があると
なんで私がやらなくちゃいけないかということは出てきて
みんな平気で使っているんだから
みんなやればいいんで
そこで自我が出てくると他人が出てくる
そうすると自分が嫌な人もいるし
いろんな人が出てきて
自分に嫌な人がいて 自分が一生懸命便所を掃除したところで
その人先に入ったならば
なおさら腹が立つのです
大体人生っていうのはそういうことは必ずそういうふうになるんですよ
また ダメになるならばどこでもダメになるという法則だからね
だから嫌で嫌で もう言われたんだからもうやったんですけど
一応しっかり掃除をしましたと
自我あったんだからね
そうすると自分に嫌な人もいる
本当はその嫌な人にやらせた方がいいんじゃないかなと怒ってもいる
命令した人が 先輩が それで悪いことに自分が掃除して終わって出ている時
先にその人が決まって入るんです
調べてください 皆様の人生も
なおさら自分の人格が壊れてしまいます
だからこの正しいことというのは
こちらで全部書いているんです
原因揃うだけ だから私がやっているんじゃなくて
ただやっているだけ 行っているだけ
行為が回転しているだけ
私が消したところで何でも成功するんです
だから座布団を置く場合とかね
まあそういう個ででもすべて学べるんですよ
座布団の４個にある あの糸をちゃんとちょこっと綺麗にする
得ることを 真ん中のものもそれなりにどこか方向へ入れておくことっていうのは何のことはないんでしょうね
瞬間にできるし そういうことができる人にはどんな仕事もできる
しかし自我がないと そこから喜びというものはいつでも出てくるんです
自分がすごくうまく すごく早く動いているということ
行為があるが 行為する主体
自分がいないという真理を理解しておくんです
まあそれ今説明しました
これが成功する基本なんです
だから成功があるが 成功する人はいない世界です
仏教はそれをよくよく怒りがあるが
怒っている人はいませんと
欲があるが 欲張っている人がいませんと
まあサンスクリット語で言えばラーガがあるが
ラクターはいませんと
で パーリ経典の中でも結構ありまして
五蘊はあるが 私がいませんと
それから無駄な成功ということで
俗世間ではたくさんあります
俗世間の成功はほとんど無駄ですからね
必要だと思う目的でも
やがて無駄になることはあります
必要やと思ってやっても
やってあと無駄ではないかと
私は音楽を買うような感じなんですね
まあまあ 聞いてみようかなと買ったところで聞かないんですね
だから無駄だったら最初から買わなくていいんだけど
貪瞋痴の感情で築いた成功は結局は無駄になります
貪瞋痴の感情で全ての生命は生きているんだから
いろんなことに挑戦して成功はしますよ
しかし 結果は自分の幸福になりません
余計な品物になるだけで
ご本人様はすべてを置いてこの世を去らなくてはならないんです
俗世間で何を成功したっても
そのご本人様は成功した人
全部捨てて消えますからね
貪瞋痴の成功は必ず悩み苦しみを伴うんです
成功したが すごく悩むことになってるんだという結果なんです
成功はしているんですが
ものすごい大変だよと
ボクシングのタイトルを取ったらね
もう 3ヶ月とかいない
誰か挑戦しますからね
もっと年下の恐怖のない人に
だからタイトルを守るっていうのは簡単じゃないんです
それで そういうタイトルで成功した人は確実にタイトルが取られるでしょ
決まってるんです  1回
2回  3回  4回  6回とかは行くかもしれませんだけど
タイトルをディフェンディングして
でも必ずこれ取られちゃうんですよ
それで人はそこで引退しなくちゃいけないんです
そこで取られる前に次の試合に出ないとことをしたら引退すると
それで出ないと言ったら
タイトルがわい 次の試合に出ないと
そんなもんですよ ですから
成功は貪瞋痴の成功は悩み苦しみと伴わないはずがないんです
そこで有意義な成功って何なのかと
結果が長持ちするもの
喜び 幸福を与えるものに成功することです
ですから 子供たちは学問に必死で挑戦することは有意義なんですよ
学んだものは一生留まるんだから
体に 四年間 六年 十年間
ほんの短い時間でしょうに
学ぶのは しかし その能力はずっとついてきますね
だからそういうものは有意義
うん 他人を助ける 人の役に立つこと
心を清らかにする努力
悪をなくす行為 善を行う行為
智慧を開発すること 解脱することは長持ちする幸福を与える有意義な成功です
まあ全部リスト書きました
もう面倒くさいんです
1字で説明するのも 有意義な成功っていうのはそういうものなんです
それで以上も以下もないんです
はい 解脱は生きる目的に達することでもあり
最終的な成功なのです
まあ仏教から見れば 最終的な成功というのは解脱なんですね
それではもうすべて苦しみが消えるし
まあやることは終わっちゃうんです
そういうことで 無意味な成功もありまして
有意義な成功もありまして
で すぐその場だけの結果ならね
無意味なんですよ 長持ちしない成功は
長持ちするものは まあそれなりに
まあそれも比較的なんですけど
まあまあ学問というのは一生役に立つという
まあインド的な考え方があってね
生涯ですから 自分の一生役に立つもので
まあそれからまたいろいろ
10年役に立つとかね
15年役に立つものとか
15年間役に立つものとかいろいろあります
とにかく長持ちする成功ですね
挑戦するのは それで解脱っていうのは
まあ無限に長持ちするんですね
はい 次に行きます キリストとブッダ
え？と思えるが 二人とも世界宗教2つの階層ですね
なんでいきなりキリストとブッダが入ったのかと
頭がおかしいんじゃないかなと
私のね キリストの場合はすごいところは神の子であること
神と子は本来的に超特権を占領しています
キリスト教という宗教の開祖様であるキリスト様がすごい人でしょ
もうすごいことをやりましたと
しかし あれは神の子だからな
あの二人が超特権を取ってるんですね
生命の中に 人間には真似できない
じゃあ私もキリストのようにというのは
これはもう何て言いますか
サクリレージになっちゃいますね
あれ 何て言いますかね
侮辱 侮辱じゃないね 冒涜
そんな一言葉言っただけでも冒涜したことになるんです
そうなりません 神は神で
人間は人間で ブッダが生命が平等の世界の存在です
ブッダの 違うところは
生命は平等の世界のたった一人の生命なんです
超特権はないんです しかし
地道に努力して生命の最高位に達するんです
神も超えちゃうんです
ざまあみろと しかし 初めは生命は平等です
平等 みんなと一緒にレベルにいた人が地道に
それでわかるでしょ？なんで比較したんですかっていうとこは
誰にでもできるのだというメッセージは仏教にあるんです
誰にでもできますよと
そのメッセージは仏教にあるんです
特権はないが 特権があるんです
仏教の場合は 生命のからくりを一切バラしてます
ブッダは 進むべき道もその方法を説かれています
そういうところは違うんですね
あのキリスト様とブッダの場合は
生命って何の明確にバラしても
きめ細かくバラしちゃうんです
それでみんな同じやってわかるんですね
それで生命は何するべきかとも教えてやって
そのやり方まで教えるんです
ブッダの過去世物語は
偉大なる境地に達するための長い道順のエピソードなのです
それで我々 今日の宣伝の中にも入り
入ってあったと思いますけど
ジャータカ物語というものがあって
それはブッダという何のこともできない
ごく普通の人が菩薩になったことから
どんどんどんどん自分の能力をね
特訓して特訓して 能力を上げて上げていって最高位に達するんです
それはブッダにできたんですけど
私たちに無理ということはありえないんです
やればできるということを
この世で経験 訓練 下積みなしでは何にも達しないんです
どう見ても祈りで奇跡で成り立つものはないんです
そこは仏教の世界ははっきりしています
祈祷では何にもなりません
で またそれでまたセクション一つ終わります